Hallo.
Guten Morgen.
Ich bin hier als Ersten tätig und heute kümmere ich mich um Sie.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja.
Vielen Dank.
Ich bräuchte erst Ihren persönlichen Daten.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Thomas Siegmann.
Siegmann.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Ja, Siegmann schreibt sich S, dann I, E, K, M, A, N, N.
Siegmann.
Herr Siegmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61 Jahre alt.
Wo waren Sie denn genau geboren?
Am 11. Oktober 1963.
Wie sind Sie? Wie schwer und wie groß Sie sind?
Ich wiege so 90 Kilo.
Ich bin 1,85 Meter groß.
1,85 Meter?
85.
1,85 Meter.
Vielen Dank.
Erzählen Sie mal, Herr Siegmann.
Weshalb sind Sie hierher gekommen?
Ja, ich habe seit ungefähr 4 Wochen starke Schmerzen.
Die nehmen an Stärke zu in der linken Schulter.
Das strahlt auch in den linken Arm aus.
Das ist so in den Oberarm an der Seite.
Und in die Hand zum kleinen Finger und Ringfinger.
Das tut sehr weh.
Ich kann kaum mehr schlafen in der Nacht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich mich hinlegen soll.
Das ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Seit 4 Wochen.
Seit ungefähr 4 Wochen ist das ja.
Begleitet diese von einem Tauchheitsgefühl?
Oder Kribbeln?
Ja, so ein bisschen Kribbeln habe ich in den Fingern auch.
Das stimmt.
Aber hauptsächlich ist es so ein dumpfer Schmerz.
Dumf, sagen Sie nicht mehr.
Ja, dumpf und so wie bohrend.
Also so in der Tiefe.
Das wird halt immer schlimmer.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Können Sie Ihren Finger gut bewegen?
Ich kann die Finger bewegen.
Ich habe den Eindruck, so richtig Kraft ist da nicht mehr drin.
Im kleinen Finger und im Ringfinger.
Aber ich kann bewegen.
Ich kann die Faust auch zu machen.
Dann haben Sie einen Kraftverlust in den kleinen Finger.
Etwas, ja.
Das ist Linken an?
Ja, links.
Stellen Sie sich ein Skala vor.
Da 1 bedeutet lachde Schmerzen
und 10 bedeutet starkste Schmerzen.
Wo würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen einschätzen?
Ja, bei 7.
7, das ist aber sehr starkes Schmerzen.
Hat dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Ich habe mal gestern eingenommen.
Ich habe den Eindruck,
dass das nicht wesentlich geholfen hat.
Ich glaube, 600 stand dahinter.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen
am Ende unseres Geschirrpress aufhalten?
Oder soll ich Ihnen einen Schmerz mitteilen?
Doch, ich kann die Schmerzen noch aushalten.
Das kann ich noch.
Wenn Sie das nicht tun,
kann ich das.
Wenn es nicht zu lange dauert, kann ich das.
Ich würde schnell das Gespräch zum Ende bewegen.
Sie haben Schmerzen.
Können Sie Ihren Arm bewegen?
Ja, ich kann ihn bewegen.
Aber wenn ich ihn so weiter hochhebe,
so als über die Waagerechte,
dann tut das besser.
Es ist auch ein Schmerz,
dass Ihre Schmerzen nicht mehr in der Schulter sind.
Wenn ich auf der rechten Seite lege,
dass der Arm nicht belastet ist,
die Schulter,
auf der linken Seite kann ich gar nicht liegen.
Rechte Seite,
dann kann ich die Schmerzen nicht mehr in der Schulter liegen.
Ich habe die Schmerzen,
die ich auf der rechten Seite lege,
auf der linken Seite.
Ich kenne sonst keine Sachen,
die den Schmerz lindert.
Das ist schwierig.
Ich konnte in den letzten Tagen gar nicht mehr richtig arbeiten.
Ich bin vom Beruf Zimmermann.
Da muss ich oft schwer heben.
Ich muss dann auch auf dem Dach arbeiten.
Da muss man aufpassen,
dass ich dann nicht abstürze.
Ihre Schmerzen können mit ihrem Beruf
im Selbenduch stehen.
Natürlich wieder.
Dann ist mir noch aufgefallen,
wie bei meiner Frau ist aufgefallen.
Sie sagt, dass mein linkes Augenlied
das hängt so runter.
Ich kann das Augen nicht mehr richtig öffnen.
Das linke Augenlied ist immer so etwas geschlossen.
Das ist aufgefallen.
Dann ist mir aufgefallen,
dass meine Popillen unterschiedlich groß sind.
Die linke Popille ist viel kleiner als die rechte.
Die linke Popille ist kleiner als die rechte.
Die linke Popille ist kleiner.
Seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Mir ist das gar nicht aufgefallen.
Meine Frau hat das gesagt.
Vor eine Woche sagte meine Frau,
dass dein Augenlied immer so runter ist.
Die Popille ist viel enger.
Sie haben aber keine Augenschmerzen.
Nein, Augen-Sperzen habe ich nicht.
Ein steckendes Gefühl?
Nein.
Okay.
Herr Siegmann, überlege Sie mal.
Gibt es noch etwas, das Sie mir sagen wollen?
Die Schmerzen sind so heftig.
Ich habe immer Husten.
Ich habe so eine chronische Brontitis.
Wenn ich so heftig Husten muss,
dann habe ich den Eindruck, du tust noch mehr weh.
Das ist auch sehr unangenehm.
Seit wann habe ich Husten?
Ich habe schon lange Husten,
weil ich ja auch so viel rauche.
Vor vier Jahren war ich mal bei einem Lungenarzt.
Er hat gesagt, ich habe eine chronische Brontitis.
Ich soll aufhören zu rauchen.
Aber das habe ich bis heute nicht geschafft.
Nehmen Sie deswegen die Medikamente ein?
Ja.
Ich nehme einmal so einen Spray.
Der heißt, ich schaue Atrovent.
Und dann nehme ich so einen Pulver.
Einmal, auch manchmal zweimal am Tag,
sagt mir der Arzt, da ist Cortison drin.
Ein Pulver.
Das muss ich so in eine Kapsel,
ein Apparat reinstecken und darauf drücken.
Dann kommt das so als Nebel.
Das muss ich einatmen.
Ich verstehe, nehmen Sie dieses Spray und Pulver regelmäßig?
Ja, ja.
Ach ich.
Regelmäßig?
Ja.
Wann nehmen Sie genau morgens oder abends?
Ja morgens auf alle Fälle und dann im Laufe des Tages.
Okay, zweimal nehmen Sie.
Ja, ja.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe noch hohe Blutdruck.
Hohe Blutdruck?
Dann nehme ich auch Medikamente.
Seit zwei oder drei Jahren nehme ich da Tabletten ein.
Was nehmen Sie?
Das Mittel heißt Kandisatan.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Da steht acht hinter.
Da nehme ich morgens eine und abends eine halbe.
Das war sehr schmerzhaft.
Die hohe Harnsäure wurde festgestellt.
Auch vor zwei Jahren hatte ich einen Gichtanfall am Fuß.
Das war auch sehr schmerzhaft.
Der Fuß war da ganz rot, jetzt große Zäh und dick.
Dann nehme ich jetzt ein Medikament ein,
damit die Harnsäure gesenkt wird.
Ja, Allopurinol?
Genau, Allopurinol heißt das.
Da steht 300.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Blutdruck?
Eigentlich schon länger, aber ich nehme erst seit zwei Jahren Tabletten.
Vor zwei Jahren hat das festgestellt, wie leid.
Ja, festgestellt wurde das schon früher.
Aber ich wollte eigentlich keine Tabletten nehmen.
Aber dann hat der Arzt gesagt, das müssen Sie.
Ich habe es schon vor zwei Jahren festgestellt.
Vor zwei Jahren war auch dieser Gichtanfall.
Vor zwei Jahren hat es mit einem Anfall angefangen.
Ja, aber dann hat der Arzt gesagt, das müssen Sie jetzt machen.
Das ist wichtig, weil der Blutdruck war zu hoch.
Mit diesem Mittel ist der Blutdruck ganz gut.
Ich verstehe.
Und diese höchste Harnsäure.
Ja, seit zwei Jahren.
Vor zwei Jahren war auch dieser Gichtanfall.
Und dieser Anfall hat es angefangen.
Okay.
Haben Sie danach noch einen Anfall erlitten?
Nein, nein.
Nur einmal, dann nehme ich Ihre Medikamente ein.
Ich verstehe.
Ich werde jetzt einige allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Diese können mit Ihrer jetzigen Beschwerden einhergehen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, glaube ich nicht.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, übel ist mir auch nicht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Haben Sie Nachtschweißausbrüche?
Ja, das habe ich beobachtet.
In den letzten Wochen habe ich häufiger,
dass ich Nacht schwitze.
Und sogar vor einer Woche habe ich dann auch mal nachts das Hemd gewechselt,
weil es so nass geschwitzt war.
Das ist in den letzten Wochen aufgetreten.
Vorher hatte ich das nicht.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein, nicht so direkt, aber häufig Husten.
Husten, ja.
Morgen vielleicht?
Ja, morgen ist es besonders, aber auch im Laufe des Tages.
Kommt auch Auswursch ab?
Schleim, meinen Sie, schleim?
Ja, schleim ist eigentlich immer dabei.
Der ist meistens so gelblich,
aber in letzter Zeit war er auch mal so ein bisschen bräunlich.
Ich dachte auch mal, da ist ein bisschen rot,
aber es ist ein bisschen rötig.
Aber das war dann am nächsten Tag nicht mehr.
Aber es ist immer schleim dabei.
Immer schleim dabei.
Wie sieht es denn aus mit dem Wasserlassen?
Haben Sie damit Probleme?
Ich muss zweimal in der Nacht auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Da war ich beim Urologen.
Der Urologer hat gesagt, die Prostata ist vergrößert.
Aber ich habe nicht mehr die Prostata.
Ich habe gesagt, ich will das mal so probieren.
Es stört mich nicht so.
Ich schlafe danach eigentlich wieder gut ein.
Nur in den letzten Wochen habe ich eben nicht mehr gut geschlafen.
Wegen der Schmerzen, in der Schulter.
Okay, aber dann nehmen Sie keine Medikamente gegen.
Nein, nein.
Aber es hat schon festgestellt, dass eine Vergrößerung ist.
Ja, ja, eine Vergrößerung ist.
Wann wurde das festgestellt?
Ich glaube, so vor einem Jahr.
Okay, habe ich Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung.
Ich habe es regelmäßig jeden Tag.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Siegmann?
Der Appetit ist ganz gut.
Letzter Zeit vieler, aber ich habe es auch.
Das ist ganz gut.
Letzter Zeit vielleicht mit den Schmerzen ist mein Appetit nicht mehr so gut.
Mein Gewicht ist auch so ein bisschen untergegangen.
In den letzten sechs Wochen schätze ich mal so 3 kg, 4 kg.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Normalerweise habe ich immer Mühe, das Gewicht zu halten,
weil es sonst zu hoch geht.
Aber jetzt in letzter Zeit ist es so 3 kg, 4 kg untergegangen.
3 kg bis 4 kg, ja.
3 bis 4 kg, ja.
In den letzten sechs Wochen?
Ja, sechs bis sieben Wochen, schätze ich.
War das unab Sichtlich?
Unab Sichtlich.
Vielen Dank.
Sie haben über einige Vorerkrankungen schon erzählt.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe noch andere Vorerkrankungen erzählt.
Nein, einmal diese chronische Brontitis,
dann den hohen Blutdruck und dann die hohe Harnsäure.
Ja, gut.
Wurde es sich schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Neugeborenes, als Zeugling,
wurde ich operiert, da hatte ich, wie nennt sich das,
der Magenausgang war verengt.
Ich verstehe.
Ich wurde an diesem Magenausgang operiert,
dann konnte ich wieder durchgehen in den Darm.
Das war als Zeugling die Operation.
Dann hatte ich eine Blinddarm-Operation,
da war ich ungefähr zehn Jahre alt.
Und im Alter von ca. 35 Jahren hatte ich einen Unfall,
Motorradunfall, und da hatte ich einen Knöchelbruch,
der linke Knöchel, der war gebrochen,
der am Sprunggelenk gebrochen,
und da musste ich operiert werden.
Der Sprunggelenk gebrochen, ja?
Ja, links, links.
Der Außenknöchel, der war gebrochen.
Außenknöchel.
Am Sprunggelenk, weiß ich nicht, obere oder was,
ich kenne mich da nicht aus, sie ist am Sprunggelenk,
das ist das.
Vielen Dank.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Arbsland?
Ich war vor drei Monaten, war ich in Spanien eine Woche.
Aber sonst war ich immer in Deutschland, in Ferien oder Urlaub.
Okay.
Bestät eine Second Bus in der letzten Zeit bei Ihnen?
Second Bus, kann ich mich nicht erinnern,
dass ich einen Second Bus hatte.
Sind Sie gegen alle impfwilligte Krankheiten impft?
Als Zimmermann hat man ja häufig mal Verletzungen,
und da habe ich schon relativ viele Impfungen
gegen Wunschtagkraft bekommen in meinem Leben.
Aber dabei dann auch so eine Kombination,
ich glaube, das ist mit Differie zusammen.
Ja.
Der Hausarzt hat letztens nachgeschaut und sagte,
ich brauche im Augenblick die nächsten Jahre keine Impfungen.
Ich soll aber jetzt, ich soll jetzt aber eine Impfung
gegen Covid machen, gegen Grippe,
weil ich ja auch diese chronische Bronchitis habe,
und jetzt auch über 60 bin.
Das wäre sehr gut, wenn Sie sich impfen lassen.
Ich verstehe, dass die postständig games sind.
Ja, sozusagen.
Also wie gesagt, die Impfung jetzt habe ich noch nicht gemacht,
da muss ich mich noch anmelden beim Hausarzt.
Impfung gegen Covid, ja?
Ja, und Grippe.
Reagieren Sie alliagisch auf Medikamente
oder haben Sie eine Unverträglichkeit gegen Überlebensmittel?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Sehr gut.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie rauchen.
Ja.
Wie viele Zigaretten täglich rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche so ziemlich viel.
Ich rauche so 30 Zigaretten am Tag,
und das schon 40 Jahre lang.
Seit Jahren lang?
40 Jahre.
Das ist ziemlich wild.
Haben Sie sich schon einmal versucht, das rauchen?
Ja, ich habe schon mal versucht mit Kaugummi
und mit Nikotinpflaster und so,
aber das hat alles im Augenblick nicht geholfen.
Das ist schwierig bei mir.
Ich kann das nachvollziehen,
aber es geht um Ihre Gesundheit.
Und ja, das ist wichtig.
Wenn Sie eine Unterstützung brauchen,
wir können Sie jederzeit helfen.
Okay, danke.
Wie geht es mit dem Alkohol?
Ich trinke so Abend nach Feierabend.
Insgesamt zwei Flaschen Bier.
Die trinke ich schon abends.
Diese 0,3 ist da, glaube ich, drin.
0,3?
Ja.
Jeden Abend?
Ich habe eine Frage, die ich aus Mediznischen gründern muss.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen oder hatten Sie Erfahrungen mit den Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Gibt es kransche Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Ja, der Vater ist im Alter von 72 Jahren
an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Wie war er?
Er war 72 Jahre alt.
Die Mutter ist jetzt 86 Jahre, die lebt.
Die Mutter hat Alterszucker
und hat eine starke Knochenbrüchigkeit.
Er hatte schon mehrere Knochenbrüche,
mal kleinen Stürzen.
Die lebt jetzt in einem Altersheim.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester, die hat Asthma.
Ist Ihre Mutter,
die hat einen Knochen schon?
Ja, so brüchige Knochen.
Die Knochen sind entkalkt
und brechen schnell.
Sobald sie mal fällt, ist gleich der Knochen gebrochen.
Eine Neigung, Knochen zu brechen?
Sie sind Zimmermann vom Beruf.
Sind Sie perverratet?
Ja, ich wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Wir haben zwei Kinder, die sind aber schon älter.
Die sind 28 Jahre alt, die leben auch nicht mehr bei uns.
Aber soweit ich weiß, sind sie gesund.
Sie sind gesund.
Vielen Dank, Herr Siegmann,
für die ausführliche Informationen.
Ich möchte noch etwas hinzufügen.
Meine Frage ist,
dass es für mich schon sehr belastend ist mit den Schmerzen.
Wie kann ich die Schmerzen loswerden?
Wir werden das untersuchen.
Jetzt werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen.
Wir brauchen einige Willgämpfe.
Ich nehme die Blut ab.
Wenn alle davon vorliegen, können wir sprechen, wie es weitergeht.
Das können wir machen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt Zeit, einige Minuten.
Nicht so viel wie in Ihrer Prüfung.
Ich möchte Sie überlegen,
wie es geht.
Was kann es sein?
Was kann es differenzial diagnostisch geben?
Der Fall ist ein neuer Fall.
Den hat mir noch nicht.
Den habe ich vorgestern erst mal überlegt.
Ich überlege.
Die Kollegen, die Fragen haben, können Sie gerne fragen stellen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
War mir Ihre letztes Hausdachsbesuch
und die Pfügelmannlogie besucht?
War mir Ihre letzte Hausdachsbesucht?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wann war Ihre letzte Hausdachsbesucht?
Was ist das?
Ich meine, Röntgen der Lungen.
Das war vor zwei Jahren bei dem Lungenfacharzt.
Der hat das gerönt.
Das war fast zwei Jahre her.
Da hat er die Diagnose gestellt.
Vor drei Jahren war das vielleicht.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Da wurde die Lunge geräunt.
Seitdem aber nicht mehr.
Wenn ich zum Hausarzt gehe,
dann heuchte er mich ab, hört mich ab.
Aber geräuntet worden bin ich in letzter Zeit nicht.
Die zweite Frage ist,
haben Sie in den Hauswährreich oder in der Achselhölle
eine Lymphknoten-Schwellung oder eine Schwellung bemerkt?
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt,
ich habe es aber auch nicht hingefühlt.
Aber wenn ich jetzt so fühle,
kann ich erst mal nichts Großes feststellen.
Okay, dann gehen Sie.
Haben Sie trockenere Augen?
Trockenere Augen ist mir jetzt so nicht aufgefallen.
An den Augen ist nur meiner Frau aufgefallen,
dass die linken Augenlied so ein bisschen runterhängt.
Und dass die eine Popille eben,
die sind unterschiedlich groß.
Das sagt meine Frau, war früher nicht.
Also der Fall ist jetzt so ein bisschen kompliziert.
Das ist eine Art,
eine Art, die man in der
Schwellung verwendet hat.
Aber ich denke mir,
man muss gucken, wo sind die Risikofaktoren
und was sind für Begleitzymptome.
Aber links,
Hand Schmerzen,
müssen wir eine
Coronasendrom fragen.
Haben Sie
Schmerzen
oder Treppenschmerzen?
Ob diese Schmerzen sich bei Bewegung eventuell verstärken
oder bei Belastung.
Ich glaube, der Patient hat gesagt, wenn er den Arm so hoch hebt,
bis zur Horizontal, dann ist der Schmerz etwas stärker
in der Schulter.
Aber direkt bei, zum Beispiel Treppensteigen
verstärkt sich der Schmerz nicht.
Also bei körperlicher Belastung
oder Herzkreislaufbelastung verstärkt sich der Schmerz nicht.
Der Schmerz ist so dumpf und bohrend.
Er ist so schlecht zu lokalisieren.
So ist im gesamten Schulterbereich so dumpf und bohrend.
Ja, und ziemlich...
Der Trammer hat gefragt, oder?
Nach einem Trauma wurde der Schmerz nicht mehr so dumpf.
Ich habe mich gefragt, oder?
Nach einem Trauma wurde nicht gefragt.
Nach einem Unfallereignis.
Nein, ich kann mich an ein Unfallereignis in den letzten Wochen nicht erinnern.
Aber bismptomatisch patiniert nach Schweiß.
Gewichtabnahme?
Etwas Nachtschweiß, etwas Gewichtsabnahme.
Permanente Auswurf.
Bräunlich, bräunlich, tingiert.
Vielleicht etwas rötlich.
Nicht gesprägt.
Ja.
Okay.
Was haben die Kollegen?
Ist die Kollegin so einigermaßen...
Nein.
Die Kollegin kann das.
Ich versuche...
Es geht jetzt nicht darum,
dass Sie eine richtige Diagnose stellen.
Sondern, dass Sie versuchen,
erst mal die Anamnese so wiederzugeben,
wie Sie sie erhoben haben beim Patienten,
mit den vorliegenden Fakten.
Und dann kann man ja über Diagnosen nachher spekulieren.
Und dann kann man ja über Diagnose nachher spekulieren.
Ja.
Okay.
Gut.
Hallo.
Schön.
Ich freue mich, Sie zu sehen.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patientin,
die ich Ihnen gerne stellen würde.
Vorstellen.
Ich möchte gerne einen neuen Patientin vorstellen.
Er heißt Thomas Siegmann.
Siegmann.
Er ist 61 Jahre alt.
1,85 m groß und 90 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich heute zu uns
wegen seit 4 Wochen
bestehender, zunehmender,
dunfer, bohre,
Schmerzen in den linken Schultern.
Wo?
Die Schmerzen,
die Schmerzen,
es gibt eine Ausstrahlung
der Schmerzen in den linken Arm,
in den linken Oberarm
und bis kleine Finger
und Ringfinger.
Wie würden Sie das medizinisch sagen?
Man könnte sagen ulna-seitig.
Ulna-seitige Ausstrahlung
in Finger D4, D5.
Also ulna-seitige Ausstrahlung.
Nicht radial, sondern ulna.
Aufsage bestehe
eine ulna-seitige Ausstrahlung.
Das ist eine Ausstrahlung.
Eine ulna-seitige Ausstrahlung.
Okay, gut.
Die Schmerzintensität
wurde mit 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Die Patientin
der Patient, der Patient.
Entschuldigung, der Patient habe
gegen seine Schmerzen
einmal in Tabletten von 600 Milligramm
eingenommen,
die das aber nicht geholfen
ihre Schmerzen zu redipsieren.
Okay.
Außer dem klackte er über
Paristisien in den linken Finger
in der linken Finger
und
eine leichte Kraft
einen leichten Kreuzverlust
in den Finger.
Ja, in welchem Finger?
Im linken Finger.
Aber welche?
Im Kleinfinger und im Ringfinger etwas.
Also
man kann auch wieder sagen
ulna-seitige leichte Kraftverlust verbunden
mit leichten Paristisien.
Ja, okay.
Ja, berichtete über ulna-seitige leichte Kraftverlust
und Paristisien.
Okay, gut.
Gibt es ein Unfallereignis?
Ist der Patient gestürzt?
Ja, der hat einen Autorunfall gehabt.
Danach habe ich leider vergessen zu fragen
das werde aber bei der Köpferin.
Wir haben das vorhin besprochen,
als Sie sich vorbereitet haben, also ein Unfallereignis liegt nicht vor.
Unfallereignis liegt nicht vor.
Der Patient berichtete,
dass
er hocheben seine Schmerzen
per Stärke würde.
Beim Hochheben der Hand
oder beim Hochheben des Armies.
Man kann eventuell sagen, der Patient hat gesagt,
wenn ich seitlich den Arm hochhebe,
dann könnte man sagen, bei einer Abduktion
ab 90 Grad über die
horizontalen Abduktion,
dann könnte man sagen, bei einer Abduktion
von 90 Grad
verspürt der Patient eine Schmerzzunahme.
Ja?
Ja, bei einer Abduktion von 90 Grad
verstürzt der Patient
die Schmerzen verstärkt.
Ja, eine Schmerzzunahme.
Eine Schmerzunahme.
Gut.
Berichtet der Patient über Hautveränderungen?
Ja, im Sinne von der Reicht der Schulter oder des Armies.
Das habe ich auch nicht gefragt.
Im Sinne von Äfloreszenzen,
im Sinne eines Zoster,
haben Sie noch nicht gefragt.
Dann muss das noch geklärt werden.
Muss man eventuell dran denken.
Gut.
Gibt es sonstige Beobachtungen des Patienten?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist ein Teil der Umgebung.
Ja, seine Frau hat ihm gesagt,
dass er
Augenlid
erunter gelingt.
Ja, gibt es einen medizinischen Begriff dafür?
Wenn das Augenlid hängt, runterhängt.
Ja, das ist ein Teil der Umgebung.
Ja, seine Frau hat ihm gesagt,
dass sie sich runter hängt.
Genau.
Da hat schon jemand geschrieben,
dass ich die Ptoze, das runterhängende Augenlid,
eine Ptoze.
Was ist noch aufgefallen?
Was ist der Frau noch aufgefallen?
Eine Anisokori.
Sehr gut.
Ja, ich fasse mal zusammen, was Sie mir gesagt haben.
Herr Siegmann ist ein 61-jähriger Patient,
der seit ungefähr 4 Wochen
über starke Schmerzen im Bereich der
linken Scapular, der Scapular-Region
berichtet mit Ausstrahlung
in den linken Arm,
seitlicher Oberarm und ulna-seitig.
Die Schmerzen werden auf der Skala
bei sieben ein skaliert.
Der Schmerz ist dumpf und bohrend.
Es bestehen im unterarmten Bereich
und in den Finger leichte Parästhesien
und auch ein gewisser Kraftverlust.
Das ist richtig, ne?
Ja.
Darüber hinaus ist der Ehefrau eine Ptosis,
links aufgefallen sowie eine Anisokori.
Gut.
Ist es bei den Patienten chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja.
ZOPD.
Erst möchte ich über den Vegetativen am Nese berichten.
Okay.
Sie müssen aber damit rechnen, dass der Prüfer der Oberarzt
selber Fragen stellt in der Prüfung.
Ja.
Dann geht es um die Frage,
ob Sie kurz auf diese Frage eingehen
chronische Erkrankungen berichten.
Dann gehen Sie zu Ihrer vegetativen Anase.
Ja, das mache ich gerne.
Der Patient leidet seit 4 Jahren
an COPD.
Er nimmt dagegen regelmäßig
Atrovenz-Preg
und Cortison-Pulver ein.
Okay.
Aber in der letzten Zeit
leidet er
unser Produktiverkosten.
Ja.
Der gerichtlich bräunlich
Parbihat.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Erkrankungen?
Ja.
Außerdem leidet er
Arteriele-Hypertonie.
Seit 2 Jahren nehme er
Kandisartan.
8 Milligramm.
Okay.
Vor 2 Jahren
habe er
ein Podogra erlitten.
Podagra?
Podagra.
Ein Gichtanfall.
Erlitten.
Dagegen nehme er Allokrinole 300 Milligramm
morgens und abends.
Erlitten.
Die Erhöhung der Hansur heißt
Medizinisch Hypercumimie.
Gut.
Jetzt habe ich sie unterbrochen und sie wollten mir etwas
zur vegetativen Anamnese sagen.
Ja.
Vegetativer Anamnese zeigte einige
Auffälligkeiten.
Deswegen musste er
in der Nacht wechseln.
Okay.
Außerdem als B-Symptomatik
ist es auch erwähnenswert.
Eine Gewichtsabnahme
von 3 bis 4 Kilogramm
binnen 6 Wochen.
Unabsichtliche Gewichtsabnahmen.
In der letzten Zeit
leide er
eine Schmerzbedingte Dyssobnie
und seitdem er
wegen Prostata
Hyperplasie
leider er
unter Necturie.
Zweimalige Necturie.
Gut.
Gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten
im Risikoprofil des Patienten
neben der Hypertonie,
neben der Hyperurikämie, bezüglich Alkohol,
Nikotin?
Er ist
ein Vorschauffaucher.
Er rauf
40 Jahre
30 Segarets täglich.
Das entschüpricht
20 Packages. Nein.
60 Packages.
Ja, 65 Packages.
Ja, das ist eine Menge.
Das ist ein erheblicher Nikotin-Abusus.
Ja. Okay.
Er rauf weiter.
Und Alkohol?
Alkohol trinke er abends.
Trinke er regelmäßig Bier.
Wissen Sie ungefähr die Menge?
1,5.
Er hat gesagt 2 Flächen Bier und jede Flasche Bier hat 0,3.
Das sind kleine Bierflaschen.
0,3 Kubik.
Und man hat auch 2 Liter ungefähr.
Aber er trinkt keine Schnepse,
nur Bier.
Ist der Patient schon mal operiert worden?
Ja.
Als er neu geboren ist,
wurde er wegen Pylorostenose operiert.
Genau.
Pylorostenose fand eine im Neugeborene
und Säuglingsalter fand eine Pylorostenose operiert.
Und weitere Operationen?
Ja.
Er wurde mit 10 Jahren apandectomiert.
Okay.
In einem Alter von 35
habe er wegen einer Motorradunfall
eine Pylorostenose operiert.
Und die Pylorostenose war nicht so.
Es war wegen der Motorradunfall
zur Stadt nach Motorradunfall
wegen oberer Schubpunktgelenk
Fraktur und Malleolfraktur
operiert worden.
Ja, also es war wahrscheinlich eine Malleolusfraktur,
eine Fibulafraktur,
die operativ versorgt wurde.
Das ist ja eine Angabe des Patienten.
Man kann sagen, wahrscheinlich
eine Fibulafraktur, die osteosynthetisch versorgt wurde.
Gut.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familienanamnese?
Ja.
Der Vater ist mit
72 Jahre alt
an Lungenkarzinom verstorben.
Ja, an Lungenkarzinom.
Und die Mutter ist noch eine Mutter?
Ja, die Mutter ist 86 Jahre alt.
Sie leidet an Diabetes Militus
und Osteoporose.
Osteoporose.
Man kann sagen, frakturierende Osteoporose.
Er hat gesagt, die Mutter hat
Nochenbrüchigkeit
und bricht sie ganz schnell die Knochen.
Man kann sagen, eine frakturierende Osteoporose.
Gut.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, die Schwester leide an Asthma.
Gut.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose
ist ein bronchialkarzinom.
Dafür sprechen
wir in der Nähe von
Belsymtomatik
Familienanamnese
und
Nikotinabusus.
Wo glauben Sie denn,
ist das bronchialkarzinom lokalisiert?
Wo genau?
Plexus brachialis.
Man kann sagen,
mehr im oberen Bereich der
Linkenlunge, also
in der Glavicularregion,
da gibt es einen Begriff für einen Tumor, der da oben sitzt.
Das konnte ich nicht erinnern,
aber jemand hat geschrieben
Pankos.
Das habe ich auch gelesen.
Es drängt sich der Verdacht auf,
dass es sich um einen Pankos-Tumor handelt.
Der leider auf den Plexus
oft drückt und dann gibt es diese
Symptomatik-Ausstrahlung in den Arm
und dieser dumpfe, bohrende, starke Schmerz.
Es sind viele Patienten berichten über sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Bei diesen Tumoren,
die teilweise den Grenzstrangen mit erfassen.
Deswegen auch dieses Symptom an den Augen.
Kennen Sie das?
Wie das heißt?
Also in Deutschland heißt das Hornausyndrom.
Hornausyndrom, wie das Horne?
Ne, Hornausyndrom.
Das ist eben die Tosis, die Myosis,
die enge Popille.
Und dann gibt es noch die sogenannten
Anhydrosi dabei.
Da hat, glaube ich, der Kollege eben gefragt,
von wegen trockenen Augen.
Das wäre
diese sogenannte Symptomen Trias.
Aber Verdacht auf Brontialkazinomen
ist, würde ich sagen, völlig richtig.
Was käme differenzial diagnostisch dennoch in Betracht?
Aus wiebeln Säure,
die Skusprolaz?
Ja, in welchem Segment würden Sie den einsortieren?
Was versorge ich die Ulna-Seite der Hand?
Das Segment C8.
Okay.
Ja, C8 müsste das sein.
C4, C5, glaube ich nicht.
Das hat der Kollege da geschrieben.
Das ist glaube ich ein bisschen hoch.
C8, glaube ich, ist mehr Richtung Ulna Kleinfinger.
Ja, 7, 8.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Aber ist egal, trotzdem differenzial diagnostisch käme das in Betracht.
Es käme eventuell eben auch,
weil die Hauteffluoreszenzen nicht erfragt wurden.
Ob es vielleicht ein herbst Zoster ist, wie auch immer.
Das muss man natürlich sehen, auch bei der Inspektion,
bei der Untersuchung.
Aber vorrangig ist, glaube ich, die Verdachtsdiagnose des Brontiakazinoms.
Bei diesen Risikofaktoren, die der Patient bietet.
Ja, aber ich finde, das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Das haben Sie sehr ruhig gemacht.
Ich habe Sie bewusst unterbrochen.
Und habe Sie kurz darauf hingewiesen,
dass das, denke ich, auch in der Prüfung mal passieren kann,
dass ein Prüfer plötzlich eine Frage stellt
und was ganz anders noch wissen möchte.
Dann müssen Sie etwas flexibel sein und vielleicht darauf eingehen.
Aber dann wieder Ihr Konzept haben.
Das ist klar.
Haben Sie gut gemacht.
Auch wenn Sie erkältet sind, ich habe es nicht gemerkt.
Ja, und ich denke mir,
das wird gut klappen und dass Sie bald einen Termin
für Ihre Prüfung bekommen.
Dass die bayerische Verwaltung mal
etwas schneller arbeitet.
Ja, ich hoffe.
Ja, gut.
Ich fand das gut.
Und auch Danke für die Kommentare
und Nachfragen der Kollegen.
Das passt.
Wollen wir uns nächste Woche wiederfragen?
Ja, nächste Woche.
Ja, habe ich.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen noch einen schönen...